hey you guys
we're doing another movie review and
guess what we're doing some more
italian horror now this is kind of a
strange one but i've been wanting to
talk about this one for a while and i
promise i promise
i will get around to doing more straight
up giallo movies and more of dario
argento's kind of better known or better
regarded movies um you know other than
the ones we've already
done on movie retrospective obviously
i'm not gonna do those over again
but uh you know there's still a lot more
i want to do but this one
i don't know this one it's like it came
out in 1985
pretty much right in between like he had
done tenebre
and then he was doing the producing and
co-writing on the d
on demons one and two and then this came
out and then after this was opera
now this movie i i don't think it's like
the worst reviewed of
dario argento's movies but it's for sure
one that's not very well regarded
and it's one that not a lot of people
have seen
i feel like even people that are kind of
into dario argento i mean i
you know it's not one of the first ones
that you go to
but for whatever reason i saw this one a
long time ago
and i don't know i just have like kind
of an affection
for it i suppose just because it's so so
80s
and it is batshit insane i mean
just as i describe what happens if you
haven't seen this movie
um as i describe what's happening in it
i think that you'll probably think that
i'm making it up but i assure you
that i'm not making it up because this
movie is just
that insane i mean but in a good way
it's super super entertaining i wouldn't
call it necessarily a good movie
but it's for sure entertaining
so i guess that makes it good like in a
way
so this movie is called phenomena now
it was originally released in italy and
its original release was 116 minutes
long when it was released in other
territories
like later on um i think the most common
version around the world
it i think they took like five minutes
out so it's like 110 minutes that's
called the integral cut or whatever it's
called but what they did was when they
released it in theaters in the u.s and
i'm pretty sure that this was the last
dario argento movie that got any kind of
uh
why i don't even know if it was a wide
release but it got like a limited
release in american theaters
and i've heard of a couple people that
actually did see it in the theater back
in 1985.
but when they released it in the us in
theaters they cut
like more than 20 minutes out of it so
they cut it down to 83 minutes
and retitled it creepers they took out
pretty much all the gore [ __ ] they took
out
a whole bunch of stuff uh and they even
like rearranged some scenes and [ __ ]
like that
i've seen both cuts but i haven't seen
the creepers cut for a really long time
so i can't
really speak to um you know i don't
really remember like what was taken out
i know most of the real over-the-top
gore was taken out because this is a
pretty
uh gory movie like a lot of you know
like most dario argento movies are the
thing about this one
is i feel like you could totally call
this
a giallo movie because it does have a
serial killer
that's going around picking off people
one by one
so it does have that uh you know and the
killer is kind of
has a weird weapon and you know i think
they even wear black gloves and a hat
and stuff like that at one point
so so it has that aspect to it but then
he's also trying to meld it with a
supernatural
thriller type of thing and this is one
of those movies where it seemed like he
just wanted to throw everything at the
wall and see if it's stuck
and like i said i think that's kind of
what makes it so batshit but also it
makes it so entertaining because
okay so having a giallo movie you know
with the killer with this kind of like
long spear thing that they kind of screw
together
like every time it's almost like a
tripod type of thing i don't know except
it's like a spear on the end
so having a giallo movie is just cool
enough on its own
but then you have an aspect of
a girl that can that has a psychic
connection to insects and can like
control them so you have that kind of
[ __ ] going on
oh and also she sleep walks and you also
have donald pleasence
playing an entomologist in a wheelchair
who has
a helper chimpanzee named inga
so any one of those three things would
like be a cool movie on its own but no
this movie has all of those things like
going on there's a lot going on in this
movie
also there's just a bunch of other crazy
[ __ ] and it's just like
like i said describing it you're
probably gonna think i'm like hi or i'm
making it up but i swear i swear to god
i'm not
uh i will say too that this was a very
early role
for jennifer connelly this was actually
a year or two before she did labyrinth
i think she was only 14 when she did
this movie she doesn't she looks a
little bit older than 14 but i'm pretty
sure she was only 14 years old when she
did this
now this movie the setup of it is very
very suspiria-like
right because you have jennifer connolly
playing a character whose name is also
jennifer
as jennifer corvino is who she plays and
she's the student of
or she's a the daughter rather of this
really famous
actor and she gets sent to
a swiss boarding school like an
all-girls school right
sound familiar yeah and then when she
gets there like a lot of the staff
are kind of [ __ ] they're not witches
obviously like they were in suspiria
uh but you know it's a similar kind of
kind of thing and then
you know there's a killer going around
knocking off the students one by one
so the opening scene of this so this
actually was shot in switzerland so it
doesn't look quite like
i mean the cinematography in this is
really nice like because it seemed like
he was trying to open this his style up
and do something a little bit different
with it
so like the shots of and i think this
was the first movie that he used to
steady cam
on as well so he was like trying to
experiment with different stuff so just
like kind of the shots of the swiss
countryside and stuff like that really
really
uh cool and then intercut with
you know it's very pastoral and then
intercut with um
these just really uh over-the-top like
gory murder set pieces like you know
mostly what he's known for but these
ones are pretty over the top i gotta say
even for him so in the first scene of
the movie you see this bus
and i guess there's like this girl who
missed the bus and she's a tourist i
think she's supposed to be dutch
even though she's actually played by
dario argento's daughter
fiore who i think was also 14 at the
time
so this girl you know she misses the bus
and she's like well [ __ ] now she doesn't
know what to do she's
you know in a foreign country so she
kind of goes looking for a house
and unluckily for her it turns out that
the first house
belongs to the murderer
who proceeds to chase her around and
then
cut her head off and the head goes like
flying over the
like out a window and over like over a
waterfall or something
so i'm like dario's got to darling's got
some issues
because he does some really [ __ ] up
[ __ ] to his daughters that it's movies
so uh oh and daria nickelodeon is in
this too who i believe was his
wife or at least his girlfriend at the
time because like they were together for
quite a while
um and i think they broke up not too
long after this
movie for up for whatever reason i think
some of it had to do with
i think he was going to cast somebody
else in the role that she played and
then she got mad and i don't know there
was
i'm sure that wasn't the only thing i'm
sure there was a lot of other [ __ ] going
on
but they broke up not too long after
this movie came out but she is in this
and she's great and she's like a bad guy
she's always good when she's a bad guy
so
after that first scene after that first
murder like the opening scene
then you're introduced to the jennifer
character
and she's coming to this swiss boarding
school her dad's super famous so
everyone's like kind of all excited but
i see he's no but he's no like he's not
a real celebrity or anything he's just
like one they made up for the movie
and she gets put in a uh in a room with
this
roommate sophie who is like has a big
crush on her dad so it's a little weird
so jennifer also sleepwalks as i said
now she's like sleepwalking
one night and she's walking around on
the roof i think of the school and she
happens to walk by
um a window of another student
and this other student is brutally
horribly murdered by
the killer that's running around and
jennifer sees it
falls off the roof and then she's she's
not hurt or anything but then she's like
running away through the woods
and is saved by an errant chimpanzee
and the chimpanzee in the woods david
inga
and inga says uh well ain't gonna say
anything obviously she's a chimpanzee
but she basically like hey come on you
know i'll take you somewhere
so the chimpanzee takes jennifer
connolly to this house which belongs to
donald pleasence
dr mcgregor i think is his name uh he's
he's being scottish
and uh he you know i love donald
pleasance but the scottish accent is a
little kind of on again off again
i don't really know why he why his
character in particular had to be
scottish i don't know why he couldn't
just use his regular voice but whatever
because i mean you know jennifer
connolly is american and she was playing
an american so i don't really get why
they couldn't just let it maybe he
wanted to do it he's like i always want
to try my scottish accent now dario let
me do it and he's just like yeah
whatever
but i don't know i don't know maybe
that's not what happened but so
so it so happens that uh donald
pleasence's character dr mcgregor
is an entomologist and he has been
investigating
uh these murders of these girls that
have been going on in this
town or whatever and his thing is
you know forensic entomology type of
thing was like that you know you can
tell how long a body's been there by
what kind of bugs and blah blah blah and
fun fact this is actually
hearing about a case where they used
insects
to solve a murder of like figure out how
long a body had been there or something
like that
hearing about a case like that was what
gave daario the idea
for this movie initially so jennifer
connolly and uh
you know dr loomis dr mcgregor doctor
louis whatever
they're like hanging out in the house
and
he notes that all of the insects
actually weird when she's around and
he's like hey you know
insects kind of have something like
telepathy or like a psychic ability
which
sure okay and uh he's like hey maybe you
have that too like maybe you can like
control
insects or whatnot because they all seem
to like chill out around you
and i think one there's like a really
weird uh there's a really weird moment
where
she has like something i think it's a
firefly or something like that like some
kind of insect
and she's letting it crawl on her hand
and uh he's like yeah the
he says something like the bug is trying
to arouse you or you're arousing the bug
or something like that it's like super
weird
so i guess the bug is just like has a
crush on jennifer connelly don't we all
i mean
she's adorable and uh she is she
actually really was adorable in this
movie
and like i said this was only like a
year or two before she did labyrinth i
think that
this might have been only her second
movie i think she'd done a movie prior
to this but this might have only been
her second one
and i think that seeing this movie maybe
led to her getting labyrinth i'm not
really sure if that's
the case or not but it wasn't a long
time like in between so as it happens so
like i said she keeps sleepwalking other
all the other girls at school are
[ __ ] and make fun of her about it
because they think she's a weirdo with
all her sleepwalking and oh
she thinks she's so great because her
dad's a big famous actor and all this
other kind of [ __ ]
like i said it's very much like suspiria
like the the backbiting and [ __ ] like
that with all the dancers except these
kids are
younger so she's sleepwalking one night
and
uh her roommate ends up getting murdered
as well
because she stupidly decides to go out
in the middle of like sneak out of the
school in the middle of the night like
to see her boyfriend even though there's
clearly a serial killer running around
but whatever
so she goes out and she gets murdered by
the you know the screw together
spear thingy whatever it is then when
jennifer is out
uh sleepwalking a firefly leads her to
a glove that has a bunch of maggots on
it
and she takes the glove to dr mcgregor
and he's like well whoever the killer is
if this
glove belongs to the killer which he
presumes that it does
he's like this um means that the killer
is like keeping all the bodies around
you know and so maybe like all their
shit's like cover with uh maggots in the
house which you know that'll be nice so
meanwhile uh so they're trying to kind
of solve that mystery
i forgot to mention too that i guess dr
mcgregor was working on this case
and you know the beginning part like
where fiori argento got killed and her
head
like got cut off and thrown over the
waterfall well
uh donald pleasant still has that head
and has it
like in a glass box and he's showing it
to
a couple investigators one of whom is
played by mikely sawabi i noticed i was
like
because i kind of yelled when i saw him
i forgot he was in it so while the
serial killing and the investigating and
whatnot
is going on jennifer is also having some
problems at the school
not only with the other girls being
[ __ ] but also the staff
particularly frau brookner who was
played by daria nickelode
thinking like thinking there's something
the matter with her so
they take her to like a hospital and
give her like an ekg they think that you
know maybe she's
not possessed but maybe they think that
she has you know because she's
sleepwalks it's like maybe she has like
multiple personality disorder i don't
know they're like jumping at [ __ ]
conclusions and at one point they even
when she's out they even like break into
her well they don't break into the room
but they go into her room and like read
her diary and stuff
in her diary she was like writing a
letter to her dad or something
and she says hey turns out i can uh
psychically communicate with bugs so
that's nice um she didn't say that
exactly but that was the gist of it
and so of course they all started making
fun of her because of that but
well shortly after that happens she
basically goes out in the hall and like
is like
like all magic powers and like brings
all these [ __ ] flies like all around
the building and they're just like oh
okay i guess she can really do that but
they're still going to be mean to her
because now they think she's like
demonic like he's like demonically
possessed and they want her out of the
school
and all this other kind of [ __ ] so as
the [ __ ] goes on um what
mcgregor proposes is that
since jennifer has a psychic link with
bugs of all types that she should in
theory
be able to find out who the murderer is
because like i said said the murderer is
keeping the bodies
in the house for whatever reason because
he likes having him around i suppose
so he's like we'll tell you what i'm
going to give you this box that has a
great sarcophagus fly
in it which is a fly that exclusively
feeds on
human bodies and you just take it with
you on the bus because
you know and it'll be able to smell
where the bodies are and you'll be able
to find the house so she so he's like
sending her out to sort of be a
detective and find out who this uh
killer is now she does end up finding
the house
uh some bad [ __ ] ensues and then
sadly i had and i had forgotten this too
because i saw this movie but i saw it
like a really long time ago
and i forgot spoiler alert that donald
pleasance gets killed
by the murderer what ends up happening
is that inga who is his helper
ape the helper chimpanzee uh
is outside flying a kite because that's
something that chimpanzees do
and the kite got stuck in the tree and
like it's trying to get it out on stuff
and then like the killer came and locked
the chimp out
so the chimp wouldn't be able to help
him and then stabbed him in the stomach
so there's actually one scene where inga
gets back inside
and is like bummed out that like donald
pleasance is dead and it's like super
super sad
like i'm sitting there watching i'm like
oh my god look at that [ __ ]
chimpanzee and saying look at that
so so what ends up happening is that
jennifer finds out who the killer is now
i will say i've seen this movie a couple
times i'm not
super clear okay well i know
that daria nickelodeon's character frau
brookner
i'm pretty sure like she's the killer
but
also she has a deformed kid
and his face is super super [ __ ] up i
mean super [ __ ] up and the first time
i saw this movie i was like
like it [ __ ] freaked me out it's like
[ __ ] freaky looking but i think maybe
the kid was killing people too i
couldn't tell how old the kid was
supposed to be
because the i think the back story was
that frau brookner
was she worked at a mental hospital or
she was in a mental hospital i can't
remember but then she got like
i think she worked there and then she
got raped
by a patient like through the like he
pulled her through the bars like up to
the bars and raped her
and she got pregnant and then the kid
that she had
looked like i don't even [ __ ] know
what like i can't describe like the way
the face looks it's like super freaky
and so that made her want to kill people
and i guess also
maybe the the little kid kills people
too because
i don't know okay so there because
there's a scene toward the end what ends
up happening is that jennifer basically
gets
kidnapped by frau bruckner and
i think like she's locked in the house
and then she finds like one of the
investigators i think is also locked in
the house like chained to the wall or
some [ __ ] like that
and then jennifer's trying to get out
and then she falls
into this pit in the basement which is
like the grossest it's like the pool and
poltergeist except like many times
grosser it's basically like body soup
you know what i mean because that's
something that you have in your house
i'm sure that doesn't smell bad at all
yeah so apparently in frau brukner's
house in the basement she has this big
unfinished basement that has
a pit in it that has all these dead
bodies and all the like soup
from all the dead bodies and uh jennifer
connolly falls in there
and it's pretty disgusting i have to say
so there's that she finally gets out
and then they're all like they're
fighting and [ __ ] like that and then she
gets away like she gets out of the house
and she runs out there's like a
motorboat so she gets on the motorboat
and while she's getting to the motorboat
like going on the dock or whatever like
the little deformed kid
comes running out and like jumps on the
boat with her with the with the spear
thing
like you know and he's trying to stab
her and everything and he stabs like the
um
there's a can of gasoline or some [ __ ]
like that and uh so she like calls all
the
bugs like calls all the flies or
whatever and then all the flies come and
get all over the [ __ ] kid and
he's like and it like kills him i don't
know somehow and he falls in the water
and then because he poked the gasoline
thing like the boat blows up and like
jennifer has to jump
it's like [ __ ] crazy it is a [ __ ]
crazy
last act i mean it's just all over the
place and then
as if it wasn't crazy enough like so the
boat blows up the kid is dead
because the flies came and attacked him
and also kind of i think he may be
caught on fire i'm not really sure
but so she swims back to shore and then
so she gets to shore and then the it's
not her dad but it's like somebody that
works for her dad like because i guess
he
she called them earlier like hey i gotta
get the [ __ ] out of here like somebody's
trying to kill me or whatever
like you know from the school so he's
coming to get her but anyway so she's
like running
on the beach and it's nighttime and uh
she's like hey uh what's your face i
can't remember what his name was
the dude that works for my dad and you
think oh she's saved and then that's the
end but no
because then from brookner comes up
behind that random guy
and just like whisks his head right off
wook just like right in front of her and
she's just like oh [ __ ]
and then frau brookner tries to behead
jennifer with
like a pane of glass or something i
don't know what it is um i saw one
review that said it looked like a cookie
sheet
which i guess all right whatever but it
doesn't work but then uh inga
the helper chimpanzee saves the day by
coming
uh with a straight razor that she
conveniently found in a garbage can
and basically straight razors the [ __ ]
out of daria nickelode's face
so like i said not only does dario
argento cut off his
daughter's head and then have it sit in
a tank
at donald pleasance's house but he also
has a chimpanzee
chop up the face of his wife
with a straight razor so
issues i guess i don't know but like i
said this movie
i didn't even mention too the score of
it is really cool
it's got it's bill wyman and uh um uh
claudia simonetti right
uh do the score but then there's a bunch
of like songs in it
and it's a little weird it's a little
jarring like because sometimes there'll
be scenes and it's like a murder or
something and then like motorhead will
start going or iron maiden these he's
like flash of the blade is in there um
and i think sex gang children like andy
sex gang did a song or i think he did
three songs for it but then i think they
only used one in the movie
so some people have said like you know
that the score is nice but like the
all the heavy metal and [ __ ] in there
it's like doesn't really work it's a
little jarring
uh which yeah i can see that it is a
little strange
but i don't know i i kind of like it
like i said this movie is just so
[ __ ] weird
that it's hard not to like it because
it's just so bizarre
and you just can't you're just like
looking at like what the [ __ ]
am i watching at this moment uh you know
why is motorhead playing what you know
who even am i it's that kind of thing
and it's just i don't know i just find
that really enjoyable so like i said i
have a lot of affection for this movie
even though
it's just it's bat [ __ ] it's a bat [ __ ]
insane movie it's a bat [ __ ] idea and
there's just like tons of [ __ ] going on
in there there's [ __ ]
iron maidens blaring it's just there's
deformed kids there's chimpanzees
there's just it's [ __ ] insane okay
it's just a [ __ ] insane movie
but that said obviously it's not one of
dario argento's best movies
but it is still like wildly entertaining
and that's kind of thing it's like it's
never
slow it's never boring uh there's always
some
crazy interesting [ __ ] going on on the
screen
no matter what so if you haven't seen it
i really do recommend it because
it's not it's not like a giant it's like
a giallo but not
and it's like a supernatural psychic you
know i can control animals kind of
thriller type of thing
also pretty sure because you know that
movie monkey shines
did george romero direct that or produce
it or something
i think that came out a couple years
after this and i think that he got the
idea
maybe allegedly for the knife-wielding
chimpanzee maybe from this movie
i mean i kind of feel like because this
came out a couple years before my
monkey shines came out at 88 i want to
say 87 88 maybe later
but i think maybe that's where he got
the idea from so this is like some crazy
[ __ ] this is the
this is so this is like argento turned
up to 11
with all of his weird proclivities
on display you know what i mean just
giving no [ __ ] at all
and i kind of like that about it i want
to do opera as well
because i really really love opera and a
lot of people like thought you know that
was one of his great movies because you
know i
i feel like a lot of people have the
perception that you know tenebre
was his last great movie that he did but
he did opera in 1987
so maybe opera was the last great one
and then after that it was kind of like
but this one even though it's not a
great movie
it's still kind of fun just because of
how [ __ ] wacky it is
and like i said it's super gory you know
the heads with the maggots and all that
kind of stuff it's just the effects are
like really really
effective you know i mean they're really
nasty there's like all like the bodysuit
pool
it's just like all kind of like horrible
stabbings there's all kind of you know
he loves like pushing people's heads
through glass windows and [ __ ] like
that's all that kind of stuff
so it's real real gory um but it also
has kind of this weird
pastoral like a little bit of a i don't
want to say like a little fantasy
element little fairy tale type of
element
to it because it kind of has that too so
it's really kind of a mixed bag it's
just like this really strange like
schizophrenic
type of movie like with this crazy
soundtrack but i don't know
despite all that i still kind of dig it
i wouldn't recommend
watching creepers because all the good
[ __ ] has been cut out of it and it
probably makes no sense i kind of
remember it making no sense
if you can find the 116 minute cut then
that would probably be the best although
i don't think they took anything of any
significance
out mostly i think the version that's on
i think it's on shutter at the moment
it's on
2b it's probably it's on a bunch of
streaming services at the moment
and i'm pretty sure that that's the 110
minute version but like i said i don't
think
that five minutes had anything that was
all that exciting i think it was mostly
just trimming
you know ends of beginnings and ends of
scenes that were just like went on too
long or whatever so i don't think it's
they didn't take out any of the gore or
anything like that but creepers i'm
pretty sure they took out all the best
[ __ ] like all the gore
and that's kind of one of the reasons
you watch these movies
so not the only reason but the gore in
this is really really good
but yeah if you haven't seen it and you
dig argento's other movies
then check this one out because it's so
argento-y that it just like
really that it kind of hurts and uh it's
just super fun
and super and you will just sit there in
disbelief like most of the time
like there's crazy [ __ ] that's going on
in this movie i promise it's like it's
super fun
but yeah so that will do it for this
flickers of fear and i will see you guys
on the next one bye